[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
Треба ставитись до Маріуполя,
насамперед як до Маріуполя.
Маріуполь ніколи не був
в Україні центровим містом,
[Приазов'я,
Маріуполь]
бо він завжди був
придатком до Донецька.
Місто було депресивне.
Робітниче місто, в якому ніколи нічого
не відбувалося і ніколи нічого не було.
Іде війна за 25 кілометрів звідси.
[Богдан Чабан
Засновник Ізби Читальні]
Місто відірване від усіх основних
каналів збуту товарів, поставок тощо.
Але місто розвивається.
До того ж розвивається так, як не розвивалося
20 років до цього взагалі ніколи.
За останній рік з'являються
чотири відкритих простори.
Люди, що перебувають у стані
кризи, вони готові до розвитку.
Тобто є два напрями —
або вверх, або вниз.
Люди сильні духом готові
рухатися вверх, розвиватися.
[Євгенія Ступник
Співзасновниця Платформи ТЮ]
Щоби розвиватися, необхідна,
звичайно, якась платформа.
Люди полюбляють говорити, що культурний
і творчий підйом відбувається,
коли суспільство почувається
захищеним і в безпеці.
[Галина Балабанова
Співзасновниця вільного простору «Халабуда»]
Маріуполь не почувається у безпеці,
але йому, напевне, просто остогидло.
Ситуація, що склалася у нас у країні,
напевне, позитивно
відобразилася на житті міста.
Прокинулись креативні люди,
почали діяти. Щось розпочинати,
і, відповідно, шукати нові ідеї
та втілювати їх у життя.
Війна змінила Маріуполь.
Це точно.
Вона зробила мене дорослішим.
Я вважаю, що вона загалом зробила
українське суспільство дорослішим.
Я би зараз назвав Маріуполь
містом можливостей.
Він має зараз, на цей момент, перевагу.
Це прифронтове місто, до якого
прикуто дуже багато уваги.
Якщо рік тому тут було депресивне місто,
постійні вибухи, що просто вибивало з колії,
народ перебував у такому
печальному стані,
то зараз навпаки — сюди потрібно
приводити щось нове, розвивати це.
Тим паче, що є вливання коштів.
Хочуть інвестувати в наше місто.
Коли людина усвідомлює,
що комусь потрібна,
вона рано чи пізно захоче
допомогти не тільки собі.
Я хочу, щоби хаб у Маріуполі був
абсолютно не гіршим, ніж в Одесі чи Києві.
Щоб молодь знала, що є таке місце,
куди можна прийти попрацювати, повчитися.
Куди можна прийти
і отримати нові знання.
Куди можна прийти і реалізувати
свій власний проєкт.
Прийти і реалізуватися.
Це простір для об'єднання людей,
де люди з приблизним складом розуму,
з приблизними цінностями, баченням
світу знаходять одне одного.
Сама по собі, одна
людина мало чого варта,
а коли людина знаходить
таких самих, як вона —
їхня спільнота починає розвиватися,
і їх стає все більше і більше.
Це дуже важливо — об'єднувати
в одному просторі саме людей
із одним баченням світу, світоглядом.
Основною причиною того,
що стали відкриватися ці простори, —
це те, що Маріуполь бажає розвитку.
Тобто він ні в якому разі
не хоче опинитися за межею.
Тією, котра відділяє жахи та мракобісся.
Ми хочемо рухатися вперед,
а для того нам потрібно розвиватися.
Маріуполь мусить змінитися.
Він не матиме іншого виходу.
У нього немає жодного майбутнього з
металургією, бо металургія наразі збиткова.
Вона знищує місто.
Робить величезний викид в атмосферу,
виготовляє продукт,
який не конкурентний,
скорочує кожного року свій штат.
Вона загибається.
І тому, в будь-якому разі, будуть
з'являтися альтернативні сфери
і однозначно буде
переосмислення міста.
Коли людина перебуває у зоні комфорту,
вона ніколи не буде нічого змінювати.
Тому, можливо, втрата роботи на
медкомбінаті у відповідального чоловіка, —
неважливо чи бував
він наливайці, чи ні, —
він, я більш ніж впевнений,
якщо це нормальний чоловік,
він мусить розуміти, що йому
потрібно навчати свою дитину,
що їй потрібно кудись
вступати, ходити до школи,
що йому необхідно
платити за квартиру.
І ця зона відповідальності, напевне,
рано чи пізно приведе його
до одного з таких закладів, —
не обов'язково до «Халабуди», —
але принаймні він шукатиме
можливості реалізації в іншій сфері.
Можливість робити щось корисне,
потрібне, важливе, гостроважливе
дійсно зараз дуже значуща.
Коли приходять люди після спікерів,
які говорять на дуже незручні теми,
але так  добре, що люди
починають про це замислюватися,
коли кажуть: «Дякую, було чудово»,
ти відчуваєш, що тобі взагалі
більше нічого не потрібно.
Ось це «дякую» — це найголовніше.
Я так думаю, може це якийсь новий
тренд, але українець це не та людина,
котра їздить із прапорцем у машині,
або не та, що носить
жовто-блакитний браслет на руці.
Це та людина, яка
готова допомагати іншим.
Чи мешкає ця людина в Одесі,
Львові, Маріуполі чи у Волновасі —
це людина небайдужа, котра
готова допомагати ближньому.
Важлива участь, участь соціуму.
Ти мусиш усвідомлювати
відповідальність.
І відколи кожний почне
брати відповідальність
і думати передусім
не тільки про свої інтереси,
а й про інтереси людей,
які живуть поруч,
то, гадаю, відбудеться
наступний злам у суспільстві,
і ми отримаємо новий виток розвитку.
Гадаю, від цього нікуди не подітися.
[Автор проєкту — Богдан Логвиненко
[Оператор — Павло Пашко]
[Режисер та монтажер
Микола Носок]
[Редакторка — Карина Пілюгіна
Звукорежисер — Павло Пашко]
[Аерозйомка — OPRST, фабрика думки «Донбас»
Музика — Polly K]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]